today we're doing a massive unboxing
this is the LG signature OLED TV W it is
the 65 inch version and it's just one of
the thinnest TVs ever it is something
that I can't even explain to you in
words and I'm hoping that I can show you
here in this video it is incredible it's
like you put this on the wall and it's
almost like it transports you into
another dimension let's unbox this so I
can show you there's a bunch of new
features in this from the previous
version I got a chance to demo this it
CES this year there's a bunch of AI
functions and of course I am really
excited because I'll be able to control
all of my hue lights in my house so
without further ado let's start the
unboxing and we're just unboxing I'm not
setting it up I have professionals
coming tomorrow to assist in fact
[Music]
so here's our directions TVs delivered
they take it out don't punch it don't
drop it
I don't know what those to me and good
thing you're here used to people to lift
what's that one mean hmm
Oh to see okay okay and start alright so
let's just take a little look at this
because I couldn't wait until tomorrow
for them to get here so here's a little
Welcome kit Oh more direction the actual
instructions it's interesting because
the whole set up really isn't that
difficult it's such a small profile the
biggest part of this is the soundbar
that everything connects into so this is
what connects to the actual TV to the
soundbar the people are gonna come here
to mount this tomorrow they're gonna
what did you do why did you take it
apart the bathroom TV has magnets so
once the mount is on the wall the TV
sort of is just magnetically held into
place and these are some extremely
strong magnets I just want to open this
up so bad
what's in here what's it say it says
front we can just use AI and tell it
whatever we want I'm not gonna be able
to sleep tonight I'm gonna be tossing
and turning just knowing that this is
down here and tomorrow's the day so some
of you guys who have been watching my
videos for a while you may notice that
this is going in sort of a newer space
I'm kind of doing a little redecorating
and moving around so stay tuned for more
updates on that but for now probably
should go to sleep it's late it's past
my bedtime one more sleep one more sleep
I'm getting so good at flipping knives
almost time to start juggling them do
you think
[Music]
I feel like I need a drumroll right now
if I can get one because it is set up it
is on the wall this is official this is
the new LG OLED signature TV this is a
65 inch they also have a 77 inch as well
I can't even imagine how massive that is
because this is already huge on this
wall you guys have to see how thin this
is like look at this Jenna can you tell
how thin this is from over there it does
I mean they don't just call it a
wallpaper TV because that's a fun name I
mean it is a fun name but they call it a
wallpaper TV because it is so thin come
show them did you see what I see so
incredibly shocking and I've been using
the one in my office all the time for
video games and watching movies and TV
shows and all sorts of things like that
but it's just looking at it
still it's just it's so impressive and
one of the things that I like the most
about this new version is it has AI
functionality so what that means is I
can basically talk to this television
like it's my friend you're not gonna
tell me it's not especially when my
friend likes to watch out to see videos
find me a video of iJustine unboxing and
lg tv
Wow which one do we want these speakers
are also incredible watch what I can do
stop playing Jenna don't you wish you
could do that to me in real life so one
of the newest features in this TV is you
can use voice controls to not only
control what you're watching but you can
control your home devices it uses AI
Finn cue with a Google assistant
built-in so it creates a Center for all
of your smart home devices using just
your voice it also works with Amazon
Alexa devices as you guys know I'm a
huge Hewlett fan so turn off all my
lights sure six lights off turn the
lights back on you got it
turning on six lights the display is
connected to the sound bar there's HDMI
inputs inside of here so anything that
you want to get displayed on the screen
you just go through the sound bar and
this thing sounds so amazing
it features Dolby Atmos sound let's get
something bumping here play happier by
marshmallow and Bastille this is the
complete opposite of happy I love this
on so much here we are okay
[Music]
stop playing so now you can use voice
control to control things that you want
to watch but it can also tell me some
things that I want to know do I need a
jacket tomorrow no it won't be cold in
Santa Monica tomorrow expect a high of
76 and a low of 63 can you do math
learning is the best I can do all kinds
of calculation try asking for the square
root of 42 the meaning of an irrational
number or his Pythagoras was who is the
Pythagoras according to Wikipedia
Pythagoras of Samos was an Ionian Greek
philosopher in the eponymous founder of
the Pythagorean is a movement it's my
favorite movement what's four possible
the answer is eight now that I've asked
her some dumb questions I think maybe we
should watch a movie find me a movie on
Netflix with Dwayne Johnson search
results for who between Johnson on
Netflix I actually have not seen Moana
what have you seen it yes change to
cinema mode picture and song will be
changed to cinema mode
Wow turn off all my lights turn on all
my lights sure turning on six lights now
I'm ready for my film well we're back I
fell off the couch one of the things
that I really like is losing all of
these AI functionality you basically can
talk to your TV in sort of a natural
language so it'll kind of understand and
interpret watching me you could say
things like turn my TV off after this
program is over which i think is great
because if i do watch TV before i go to
sleep i don't want it to still be on
when i wake up in the morning find me
some yoga videos on youtube here are
youtube video
for yoga yes bring the feet together
they're together
my legs are I'd rather watch a movie the
do yoga bless you thanks
so are you find me planet Earth on
Netflix search results for planet Earth
on Netflix they're so cute
know who doesn't have a partner and they
Oh boos albatross waits for his make
each husband six months apart oh my god
I'm too emotional for this stop playing
she's late she's late classic woman I
should know cuz I am one when you're
watching TV especially in the dark it is
shocking to see the perfect blacks and
the infinite contrast now this is all
made possible by the self emitting LG
OLED pixels everything is so true to
life it's such a rich color and sharp
contrasts
that you really feel like you're inside
of the movie or whatever it is that
you're watching you can look through
this thing I also love check this out
I can make this into a window change the
standard mode alright this looks like an
actual picture frame one of my
highlights at CES when I saw this TV is
it can also playback higher framerate
videos so we can go up to 120 frames a
second and shooting slow-mo videos as
you guys know is probably one of my
favorite things so I'm constantly
shooting videos in at least 120 frames a
second we have so much high frame rate
content we should put together a short
film thank you guys so much for watching
if you guys want more information about
this LG oled signature wallpaper TV I
will put all of the links in the
description and you guys can check it
out if you haven't already be sure to
hit subscribe make sure you ding the
bell so you'll be notified when I post
new videos I'm gonna go watch some of
this beautiful crisp content everything
is awesome Oh find me the lego movie
[Music]